what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to watch today and or
finale time joined of course
John Hi how are you all right give me a second
oh good I'm feeling rebellious I'm ready for
a finale how are you doing oh John yeah leave
a like people Everyone leave a like please
go ahead and do that use the force to subscribe
and click that notification Bell to get notified
when we got a reaction up here on this channel
that might be of your interest and as always
and I want to say a special thank you to all
who have joined our patreon page you guys
have been saviors in our lives so thank you
very much full-length stretch watch along
as we sync up with your own copy for Andor
available for super sexy rejects along with
a bunch of other shows that we covered exclusively
with reaction highlights and watch alongs
included over there all right ladies and gentlemen
May the force be with you
gorgeous as always
that lens flare just there was a tribute to
JJ Abrams Easter egg
like a Deidra coming into her own
wow the dark side Looms on pharynx today
who's that hologram of is that Andrews I guess
so it must be maybe he's trying to like alter
it or something I spoke to Cassian what he
called the shop ow picked up the old box line
and there he was and I said his name a hundred
times he asked about funerals nice walk
spies everywhere
building some kind of weapon it's like a bomb
I'd be losing my mind one another
just one there's a trap get him drunk enough
to talk why worry it though it's not like
he knows about it I guarantee you he's got
no idea what's going on Bank on that don't
be so sure dude you know something I don't
do me a favor keep it that way oh you're clever
you're gambling again nonsense and here in
Coruscant that's ridiculous do you have any
idea how tired of this I am
it's alive
you can't live without a casino fine you go
to Kanto bikes I feel like she was gonna name
drop it best subplot I was on my way to pick
you up this guy I've been watching his ISB
he's a guy in town his boss showed up tonight
good to see you too the mission comes first
he returns
not even wearing his hood
I really wish he grew that beard back stand
back let it drip look how quickly that's cleaned
up 500 credits each people don't look down
the way they should and I look down I don't
look past the Russ trash and treasure interesting
so is it a metaphor that he's that thing yeah
it just needs to take a dunk what are you
doing here just keeping an eye on the place
till we sell it where is she oh God where
is she oh no no no no that that's the final
thrust of fighting in this Rebellion tyridine
requires constant effort it breaks it leaks
Authority is brittle oppression is the mask
of fear remember that I oppression is the
mask of fear it will come when all these skirmishes
and battles these moments of defiance will
have flooded the banks of the Empire's Authority
and then there will be one too many one single
thing will break The Siege pharynx Will Rise
um for this to go down at his mom's funeral
how fitting the control position is here here
and here will have snipers in a containment
unit there containment yes snipers know I
want him taken alive I want that message passed
along the line clearly you should pass that
message along yourself
this episode is spies and paranoia mon mothma
is of great interest here having her husband
dig a hole for himself could be helpful in
many ways it sounded like Perrin had done
this before they've made some odd banking
you can close out your Anto Krieger files
how many attacks still counting the bodies
walked right into it it was ever before they
started wow
that hood is gonna blow right back down I
hope Nico finds his way here just swims to
ferricks I learned to swim
off camera
foreign
oh what a tight hug I told her I was coming
back stop I never should have left that morning
stop he told me you'd say all this tell him
none of this is his fault it was already burning
he's just the first Spark of the fire I when
the day comes those two pull together he will
be an Unstoppable Force for good oh wow
I love him more than anything he could ever
do wrong oh take that love into the feet of
that door
Where it All Began morlano one that's weird
I'll be in actually yeah
[Music]
Somewhere Out There Star Wars theories falling
asleep
he almost hear him snoring now
I don't want to go live gotta find him we'll
kill him where will they take him the hotel
that's our Target you just need him dead before
they start asking questions interesting nah
I'm trying to hold back from telegraphing
right now and I have a feeling I know what's
going to go down
I like how there's barely any music it really
puts you in the midst of everything
[Music]
it's like serving as a funeral March and as
a prepare for battle March not too different
when you think about it
away get these people off the streets
man this is so cold they're just trying to
mourn surrounded by the bricks of the Dead
[Music]
recognizes walk yeah
double the reward you found it I want twice
as much and a ride out of him when it's over
where is he pretend you're arrested me
got it they're ready they just want to pop
off any way they can I need him alive Don't
make me say it again oh poor B you charged
up enough to mourn
[Music]
ah it's like mirroring uh andor's flashback
foreign [Music]
from work
oh wow that's great the music's all coming
from in show yeah that's awesome all diegetic
oh brilliant what are you gonna reverse all
of us yeah brilliant oh ferrick's Rising [Music]
[Music]
[__] some [__] spots go down
I love the way they do the cultures
my name is
happening I was always eager always waiting
to be inspired the Dead Lifted Me with their
truth
oh you have a change of heart there man did
and I earned to lift you I want ferricks to
continue in my waning hours that's what comforts
me most but I fear for you oh these above
head shots man climb we took their money and
ignored them we kept their engines churning
and the moment they pulled away we forgot
them because we had each other great speech
we were sleeping and I've been turning away
from the truth I wanted not to face there
is a wound that won't heal at the center of
the Galaxy there is a Darkness reaching like
rust into everything to everything around
us we let it grow and now it's here the Empire
is a disease that thrives in darkness it is
a never More Alive than when we sleep holy
[__] [Music] it's easy for the dead to
tell you to fight and maybe it's true maybe
fighting is useless
rise up today perhaps it's too late I'll tell
you this [Music] if I could do it again I'd
wake up early fighting yes yes all right
fight the Empire
oh you son of a [__] kill him bring me
his head oh
riot [Applause] fight back Rebel
nicely done [Applause]
coward crawl buddy coward
do not shoot the Anvil man I gotta get out
of here I've always here it wasn't she great
come on dude make some damage back there
[Applause]
yep it's time dudes come on do it
yes
land her right on top of it oh
[Music] whoa ow I thought Cyril's gonna take
that yeah combo
wow that must have killed everybody
hey so much for taking the emperor's mind
off about Donny look at this fight Santa did
not prepare for oh my God the rebellion's
here
yeah
come on let's crack some helmets oh he had
buttered the helmet and he went down
got them hard skulls on ferrets
thank you oh my God
pull that helmet off Stormtrooper can aim
no
[Music] oh no oh good squat what are you doing
here oh [Music]
shazbot man that felt personal yeah
get me out of there protect me at all costs
[Music]
wow oh my god oh
dang armor plated hat appreciate that for
capturing this in such like a ugly way it
is the benefit of not of like laser blasters
not being bloody as you can just see how nasty
this all is
[Music]
that dude climbed that Tower forever for nothing
Terror apart oh my oh my God right now
oh they got themselves a hostage oh Cyril
that's Cyril is that Cyril that's Cyril
kiss her you fool come on
I love you oh my god kiss you freaks you Natural
Born Killers you and they're gonna go all
the way in that closet right now damn Andrew's
barely even in the fight
so frustrated what about this everything goes
pause it empty
bleeding it's fine it's blood not hurt it's
not mine ultimate badass line
give me those don't go you go now we'll forget
it kiss him you fool
oh [Music] Jeremy Cassian come on it's your
only family left can they make it to ganji
Moon if they ever make it out of here you're
not coming stay low all the way too far side
sea the moment you get over the water you
climb and turtle no cons Ole you understand
yeah you're not coming no no I never got to
see you oh I'm counting on you you always
say that and you always come through get them
out of here you'll find
that I'll find you now go go go fly you fools
time for a wedding
God the mom's the Bride of Frankenstein
make him a bride
okay what game is this
no game kill me or take me in
[Music] but I won 50 000 credits you promised
from before I gave back to Crystal well done
well done teams mcgeebs they did good that
episode didn't they what spots I know so they
do good buddy
[Laughter]
nice oh my goodness all that hard work
oh wow that's so cool [Music]
that is an image yeah foreign
are you
building parts for the Death Star but you're
building parts for the most lethal part of
the test yeah the most what life erasing part
of the Death Star crazy crazy stuff that should
cry let's talk about it you mother F words
all right that was a wonderful culmination
episode everything came together in the end
it did it all worked out it all worked out
everything turned out remember the beat's
going to be here everybody wins no I loved
uh marva's speech um given her own eulogy
that was great A Goodbye message kind of reminds
you of like when my first thought was actually
um oh my God who did uh would Jim Carrey play
a man on the moon oh Andy Coffee I have any
coffin um oh of yeah like prepping something
in advance I mean many people do that and
I thought it was great that you know like
it was such a bummer that she stayed behind
in a big part of her reason to stay behind
was to give Fuel and provide help and be a
part of the rebellion in some way because
she could feel that there was a rise happening
but her her death and the Gathering and Her
speech was the linchpin to it all yeah and
I thought that was so beautiful that this
all got to go down at her funeral like there's
no other way she would have wanted this funeral
to go down and granted did she want her some
her own people to die from Ferris not no However
the fact that the Rebellion did for the ferrics
like this this was such a Monumental moment
and watching this rise happen and um you know
one thing I remember when I first walked out
of Rogue one and I think we shared the same
sentiment here was that that movie kind of
put the war in Star Wars and this really did
that into an even more Grim effect because
you know you're like good let's go let's go
but it never turned into badassery the way
you think it might turn into yeah it stayed
very bleak and just so so sad the entire time
it felt like you see the ugly side of War
here or even in Star Wars a lot of the time
it is like rousing and spectacle and whatnot
yeah and never never turned into that it it
remained that this felt like a real brutality
and uh like a real war zone basically is what
I'm getting at it's about like actually seeing
blood so yeah but it the way that the images
they chose to to capture would like the police
holding the front line and the bashing the
people with their uh batons you know and opening
fire into the crowd yeah yeah it was really
ugly and like thematically I just thought
everything tied in and plot wise everything
you know unfolded together too with all the
characters coming together at this one meeting
point and I do feel like it is a completion
of a season one as because yeah it ends on
a cliffhanger and not that I feel like the
story would end here but I feel like the specific
chapter they decided to tell because we've
gone in you know like every three to four
episodes it was kind of telling a new chapter
of the season and then here they brought it
all around where it sort of felt like part
one of a novel sure you know or like the first
the first novel in a series of novels yeah
yeah and and I thought they did an excellent
just Exquisite job but you know bring up something
different yeah no two things this was this
was so so rich and and yeah I thought that
they it's like Rogue one it is really well
proportioned as a movie because it is like
the story of one particular battle and this
great fodder for a war movie whereas this
is yeah honing in on there are battles there
is the actual fight but so much of what war
is is the strategizing and the build up and
the really harsh decisions and the weird things
that you have to live with in the ways in
which you have to cross your own moral boundaries
and yeah this was very this was rousing but
in a completely uh different kind of way because
yeah you do associate I associate you know
Star Wars with a certain amount of hope uh
and then and not to say that there isn't hope
but it's it's showing you just how much you
have to put into hope like I feel like people
look at Hope as this external force that lifts
you up but you have to fill that well and
you're watching you know over the course of
this season as Cassie and Andor commits to
going to that well and and nurturing that
well and I thought it was really beautifully
handled the way they brought everybody that
seems so disparate and and and that was never
really telegraphed this way but they brought
everybody here and you see how everybody is
and isn't mostly isn't prepared for this and
I thought that was a really cool thing because
we've watched so like over the season all
these machinations all these plans being built
and especially through characters like Deidra
and Luth and you see the two sides that are
very assured of their hand and even though
there are variables you see the the prowess
of strategy and here everything comes together
in a complete mess for everybody which I think
is especially striking but it puts the hands
back into the it puts the power or at least
the momentum the moment back into just the
people's hands like I love that as much as
you have all of our main figures of The Ensemble
throughout this episode and you have that
tension of their proximity and kind of what
each of them what role they're playing so
much of what really is impactful about this
episode is just what the people of pharynx
as led by Marva choose to do and then we zoom
into these little personal moments in between
that but I think especially for again a Star
Wars series honing in on the idea of War I
think that's a really beautiful thing because
it does kind of show it in a stark sense and
I think it's the first time I've ever watched
something like this and thought to myself
you know what I'm happy that there isn't blood
with these blasters because for what this
is we can level up and we can use the fact
that you can get pretty gritty and pretty
harsh and pretty you know uh realistic to
a degree with violence you know if you do
not have the blood and so here I thought that
plays to a really great great effect a really
harsh effect but an effect that really grabs
you and it's like this I'm sure it's happened
before but this is the first time I can remember
where like the the culmination of the the
just the all the pent-up emotion that boils
over at the start of a battle really hit me
in this episode so you're watching them process
through the street when it became clear that
the funeral procession was also about to become
a full-on fight a full-on like rebellious
act in the moment like that really moved me
like this is a really moving episode in a
way that I didn't ever really expect but I'm
I'm just as the best of Star Wars can give
you that like whoop your fist and like yes
you know that catharsis this was a wholly
different catharsis but you know a part of
that same picture of hope you know just in
again the harsher more formative stages of
what that hope can do and be and the fact
that you have to you know shine that light
so intentionally through the dark um but yeah
this is this was I mean I feel like this is
gonna sit with me and sort of process through
my system for the next several days but I
was really wowed by this and as a culmination
of the season I just hats off so much of the
discourse about Star Wars is about like who
had a plan and what that plan amounted to
and this series feels like the product of
excellent planning and an excellent grip on
themes first and foremost yeah and I like
that uh they had this attention to detail
with luthin and Val and all of them as being
the center point for where the Rebellion really
sprung up and it did you know without Donnie
being the a major moving point so turning
that needle even for Marva like if that didn't
happen Marvel wouldn't have been moved to
do what she to stay would ferricks and perhaps
even give that speech you know and I I like
that you they show up and it's like they don't
they're not even prepared for for this yeah
you know and yet you have of course I'm blinking
on the name now the book the one who left
behind everything for Android yeah like you
even bring that back around and you see that
he that and or has been absorbing all of that
because you know he is that character in this
series where him being such a centerpiece
for it all and like everyone's here just preparing
for we're looking for Android we got to get
Andrew we gotta kill land or yeah you know
that's what it's all coming down to and yet
they're they're so focused on that they're
they've kind of turned a blind eye to the
fact that oh wait we got all these other people
here that are actually feeling a lot of hostility
and really not handling the oppression you
know like they're ready to throw down and
I like that Lutheran and Velo they're not
even prepared for that yeah when this is such
a big cause for why they exist and what they're
fighting for and this all stems within the
the family of Andor you know and I like how
Cassian through his journey being that art
type character who you know you can tell that
obviously we know you know from catching up
with him in Rogue one or whatnot that he's
gonna be that guy who is like so resistant
towards resistance who's so resistant toward
the rebellion and and doesn't believe in it
but through all the cards that keep being
dealt his way he's moved through to joining
the rebellion in the end of course bringing
it back full circle from that fourth episode
when he is on the ship with luthin and Lutheran
is trying to convince him into fighting for
it and with I forgot his name again what the
hell um I call him Ecom oh man like I know
that's on it uh with nemec and there's always
and in Marvel too you know always trying to
instill the willingness to fight back and
fight for this cause and it's taken a lot
of sacrifice and a lot of personal movement
and experiences for him to get to that point
that didn't feel cliche in how we got there
it wasn't just like marva's Dead all right
I'm I'm now feeling it because she died and
I got to do this for her did it turn into
that which is what I thought they were gonna
do and it it didn't go down that path I mean
sure it's a part of it I imagine with this
character but so much his performance is so
internal but you can pick up on it just from
the littlest bits of details even from him
going into the prison uh and and seeing just
wow these guys are not messing around you
know they they don't even give you a second
chance at life at any capacity so I I love
the way how we got and or to the closing point
of I'm going to fight now not for money not
for monetary and not to escape and not not
for just pure selfish reasons or anything
like that it is because he has found a reason
to fight in this rebellion and it's something
that he now believes in so they've they brought
that all around with the characters too like
I love the little look of exchanges that already
has with Lutheran at the end this whole time
wants to kill him but he can like that smile
he gives that little yeah absolutely a little
tiny smirk of Hope like he's coming he's coming
he's come around this sandor he's coming around
he's part of it now um I love that I think
I think that was really great I think some
things I could have used a little bit more
flushing out for me are Val and cinta Santa
I mean sinto feels like a is like an important
character but I'm gonna use a little bit more
detail with her and and getting to know who
she really is it's just a little bit better
and there are some people on pharynx who I'm
like I really like them when they're there
but I I wish I I got to know them a little
bit better to to care a tad bit more about
them you know yeah who we have checked in
with periodically um so yeah there are some
things there that I feel like can be um explored
a little bit more come the next season and
yeah so we didn't really get a good a solid
like we really just got like a cliffhanger
with mon mothma we didn't really get a chapter
closed so much other than you know with her
getting the money and handing off their kid
yeah yeah like that's a good Cliffhanger but
I I felt like we could use a more of a chapter
of clothes for that yeah I like how hers ends
on such a dark note you know like everyone
else's kind of ends on a semi hopeful note
if you're one of the good guys one of the
protagonists but hers is just so so Bleak
oh yeah it's like everybody is everybody on
the ground is stepping out of the shadows
and now she has to step further into the Shadows
yeah it's all aimed toward the same goal but
yeah how much how much more harsh in the moment
in in a way personally at least that that
seems yeah so I actually I do like where it
ended with her I'm not saying I don't I don't
like it I do like where it ended with her
because of that contrast it just feels like
a step rather than like a whole Arc yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah um but you've been watching
or descend through this whole season and I
do like how just uh unprepared the empire
was for what came their way in this episode
too yeah which felt like a realistic way of
depicting it into a certain extent because
they are just so they underestimate and they're
so focused and you know they did bring it
back with um Krieger dying and even with the
ISB officer saying you know like this this
was about I forget what exactly would this
exact sentence was but you know it was this
it was to send the statement and to and to
wipe it clean which is what Lutheran wanted
was for them to feel like they have ultimate
power over this like oh they just walked right
into this and it was easy peasy so now the
emperor's happy yeah the emperor's happy and
because of an incident like that it probably
made it easier for what happened at Ferris
for them to fight back too just like that
little bit of an uh give enough to underestimate
that can give more power so I I thought that
was great and like Deidre and Cyril even coming
together you know I want Twisted ass Duo here
but I I like them together I do they're creepy
as hell together I like them there's a bunch
of freaks those two yes I'm very excited to
see who they become in season two they're
gonna have a very kinky relationship moving
forward I can I can already tell yeah yeah
yeah that was great um and the use of music
too like you pointed out that there's so much
just Foley and so much just um you know natural
sound and then they have these extended patches
like there's a little bit of score music because
I started to pay attention but I love that
yeah you have so much that's just sound effects
of the environment and then you have this
long extended sequence of Music where the
music itself is sort of the main character
and everybody else is focused in on that and
it's completely motivated by what's on screen
like there's so many really Lively creative
choices throughout all this too like as as
great as like the storytelling and the writing
and all that stuff is like it's also really
beautifully realized and and you know is one
of the most immersive Star Wars shows I feel
like we've had in a way as much as I loved
galavanting about the Galaxy and there are
things I love about you know each of the series
this one feels the most like you're just there
yeah yeah well it sucks you into it's mood
and that atmosphere this episode in particular
because of its Choice with its more longer
lasting shots and with um the one to when
to use music when not to use music and then
a big portion when you got the music was just
from the procession you know like that letting
that drive the mood more oh that was great
too that b it was the one to um project the
Hologram yeah and then what a half-assed attempt
that one guy to cover it up that is big guys
coat I don't know like if you didn't do that
man they might not have fought back there
might have been still some hesitation one
is great because they don't wink at you and
they don't go haha he was right about uh you
know the Empire back in the you know in the
prison you know and and you know you can see
how I I loved that basically that you have
the whole Krieger thing play out in the background
almost the entire time and I love that even
the guy here is like you guys are you using
hear about this creatures like I feel like
it's been a detail it's been kind of hard
for people to keep track of but I love that
you have that and then you kind of come back
around to a situation you watch so many people
even on a low scale like the guy uh um the
two guys who tip off the uh Imperials that
andor's here and get them looking for him
you know the guys who betray them like you
watch so many people agree to letting circumstances
happen just so that they're and your opponent
won't be any the wiser and then you end up
in a situation where both sides are not the
wiser about what's about to happen and so
yeah it's it also kind of gives a good kind
of call to both sides that you got to really
be paying attention oh most definitely yeah
most definitely yeah and even with Bix like
where you're talking about with with hope
I think the one person who and or directly
gives hope to is mix you know she's someone
who is completely hopeless at this point and
doesn't even know she's physically all there
like she has a lot to regain physically and
mentally yeah you know uh after the torture
she endured so that moment at the very end
where they all felt like there's hope within
Andor yeah when they are getting away I thought
was really powerful and really elevated the
Android character himself yeah so yeah there's
I think there's a lot of Beauty on display
in this episode and I think it was just fleshed
out really well with uh with uh with the more
human side of the war in Star Wars I would
say like even the after effects that you see
when when the wars when the battle's done
and you're cutting around and seeing some
people who are just drained and tired and
emotionally distraught I appreciate that that
like like I said it's it there's more of it
like an adventurous Spirit usually within
the battles of Star Wars and you don't really
get this side where you just see people are
torn apart and uh it makes you I made me appreciate
it and so yeah I think you really capture
the human side and I feel like that's kind
of the point of this this series is to show
you the The Human Side of the rebellious spirit
and that usually starts with hopelessness
so yeah well and two so much of I guess the
last thing is I feel like so much of again
Star Wars has these really iconic heroic characters
and one thing I appreciated about Rogue one
that I think they've also carried over in
a beautiful way here is the way in which a
a person who maybe played a brief role can
be so important it's like nemec hasn't been
around for a while and yet he feels like a
real presence in this episode and like a crucial
presence and even having Andor the complaint
many people have of like Android even really
seem like the fully main character I feel
like that even still goes to kind of bolster
that overall theme of like you do see where
his Arc and his journey and why he is at the
center of all this but also you see the contribution
of so many other smaller players who might
not be you know hoisted to the level that
a Luke Skywalker kind of character would be
or anything well it's not like the show seems
disinterested in Andor and nor does it seem
like they're forcing Andor to be the star
yeah you know uh I think that they they could
have put themselves in a position where it
felt that way or like literally they're not
that interested in writing Android version
everyone else yeah uh but they I think they
naturally make and or the center of the show
and I think he does a great job I think Diego
Luna is a really like an excellent job it's
like yeah the other characters are more exciting
and and uh they're fresh they're new and they're
sometimes we're just given more to do in in
acting wise and plot wise you know so sometimes
you do give them more stuff uh but Andor is
the main moving puzzle to all this yeah you
know uh he's not exactly like Mad Max kind
of you know yeah you watch him go from Mad
Max to the you know yeah I mean kind of to
if he really if Mad Max really found a cause
that he wanted to stick with for the rest
of his life yeah you know instead of moving
on to the next one yeah yeah and I do think
uh the post credit scene was fun um yeah tying
it back to the desk I mean I thought it was
I think a lot of us might have thought that
right they were building [__] for the
Death Star I was just more like a timeline
of this right because they that they get um
or so Galen uh to start building it uh when
did that start like okay Jin was a child are
they like the same in age her and Andor so
that would make sense if they're already starting
development on it yeah yeah yeah that's far
that far along especially yeah yeah because
it took him a very long time to build that
thing so yeah when did they break ground of
the Death Star
to put that together so you know and I think
like maybe next season is when you do see
krennic or you do see Galen um and you probably
get k2so like that's where you get the Rogue
one characters who come in yeah get melshi
back yeah I think you'll get I think you start
to get more of these other characters here
which is fun yeah and then we could finally
get Andor and mon mothma meeting each other
if Bob Iger agrees the green light let's keep
season two AJ just started shooting today
did they apparently we gotta start shooting
him
our numbers haven't been the best quick screaming
is already start shooting before he says no
start shooting we're gonna be shooting till
next summer I don't know we already started
shut us down now it cost you more money yeah
that's not a don't be a don't be a Warner
Brother just air it don't don't tax write
off us yeah alrighty well um yeah this is
a slam dunk I thought every episode was great
uh it wasn't a weak episode of me I mean some
are more exciting than others but uh in terms
of was there a week episode no this was uh
very a wildly consistent show in my opinion
I know there's a big part of the fan base
it didn't rely on the old streaming show just
make the opening and the ending good and whatever's
in the middle is up to the fans yeah no yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it wasn't just about getting
you to watch the next episode and it felt
like the appropriate length too which is almost
shocking these days and I feel like you know
as much as I like the week to week I feel
like it'd be a good binge sure yeah yeah it's
it's it's just a well unified piece yeah for
sure for sure all right guys what did you
think about the Andor finale of the show hit
the landing for you leave your thoughts down
below it's kind of crazy how like book of
Boba Fett ended in a city with the people
fighting back and stuff and and they did this
too in the hometown Turf but just so much
more interesting this feels he has so much
more real yeah it's like a fun house all right
guys that's nice for the patreon
Gabriel Gabrielle ah beat me to it our Guardian
Angel here yeah you've been a patron of ours
for six months and I want to say thank you
for being part of our page for these last
six months I hope to see you for another six
months uh please know that your support has
been not overlooked it has been very much
instrumental in our lives so thank you for
thank you for being you and for being as generous
as you are and for not asking much from us
despite giving so much to us uh that's the
kind of people we are we like to receive not
the biggest fan of giving to take so you know
I think it's a fair relationship and I think
you've found the right ground with us here
so thank you Gabriel for the right people
to enable I hope you have uh I hope we have
a great holiday season I hope you have a great
Thanksgiving and I just wanted to say thank
you so much Gabrielle for uh being here and
look at any information your orders this oh
is that is that Quebec are you in Quebec are
you quebecois and being the great white North
living up in America's hat what is that Quebec
yeah up in Canada [Music] nice to know you
no wonder you're so nice yeah we we you're
a quebecian yeah well thank you so much and
uh I hope that you have a great rest of your
Thanksgiving my friend Mel C and uh I will
not okay
hey everybody thank you [Music]